this is really modeled around the Dallas
chess club idea they have a Friday night
tournament and that I started playing
many many years ago when I started
living in the US and it was more or less
like this the first round every GM would
put like a 1500 and every year they got
stronger and stronger and stronger they
started out basically with no knowledge
and then they got stronger I mean they
started playing against us and they
started learning from their mistakes
until you know many years later they
started actually beating us
so those what I wanted to do that in st.
Louis we still don't have the
opportunity for a lot of amateurs to
play grandmasters in the real setting I
just had the privilege of playing for
awana it was quite a surprise I look at
it as an opportunity a privilege and an
honor to play against the one of the
number one players in the world it was a
great a great opportunity so I enjoyed
the experience everybody did I mean you
know it's just short tournaments for fun
and